did you know though that we are in the
middle of the Renaissance have you heard
of this your fans started it I have
heard of it okay it's literally blowing
up everywhere everyone keeps calling it
The Renaissance which I think is amazing
look at the ceiling yes to just admire
our shortened images
or characters I played in movies I think
that I'll do it we'll just put it in
that jungle and he's reaching out
touching fingers with yes with which one
over there
um how does it feel though people are
like freaking out yeah it's nice to have
that recognition yeah it's nice to work
really hard on something and then have
people recognize you for it I agree I
love that yeah so you're getting a lot
of love for the whale which is
incredible but just you just surprised
fans which it's incredible we're gonna
get to that because it's so incredible
but I love this about you because this
says a lot about your personality which
means we could be friends because you
showed up at a mummy screening dressed
up as your character is that true
is that true subliminally dressed yes I
loved it in inference I love this all
right yeah this was in London did they
freak out yeah they made a lot of noise
I would have lost my mind I tripped
walking on the stage practically
because that's just I'm a klutz but um
it was wonderful they they ran a double
header of the monthly Mummy Returns they
projected it in 35 millimeter glorious
35 millimeter oh that's cool and um
there are a lot of fans and it was it
was in Britain right and that's where
you actually Shot the movie right uh
part of it yeah it was all in studio
there and it was also in Morocco but it
was nice to go back and say hey thanks
for making such a great movie
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
guys I'm going
[Music]